a government Health Care System you know
you could tell me that you don't want it
in the U.S but you can't tell me it
doesn't work because we've seen it work
in every other major industrial system
in different forms so what does that
usually involve what does universal
healthcare involve so there's different
varieties in the UK for instance they
have a National Health Service in which
uh medical personnels and hospitals are
run directly by the state it's almost
like a mini Soviet system to be honest
but just for health care and it works
pretty well just for healthcare
um and I think it's one example of the
way in which you could actually take the
market so I give you a vision of
socialism that involves a lot of Market
but I think there's certain spheres
where you could remove the market from
and still have
um an efficient system
um in part because you know this is a
area in which we
people don't have
obviously for cosmetic procedures
whatever they have preferences but for
most routine things that people do in
healthcare they just need to see a
doctor you know they need to get
diagnosed
um some of these systems have had
trouble with waitlist for Specialists or
whatever that's more like an allocation
problem of if you want more Specialists
you pay Specialists more like this is
just problems that could be solved by
like through the mechanisms of of
planning and and government-run health
care so that's that's kind of the most
left-wing that you could get is what the
system the United Kingdom
um beyond that you have a system like
Medicare for all where you say all right
most of the doctors besides for public
hospitals already exist
um are going to be privately employed by
Hospitals now hospitals are going to be
private
but
um instead of having all these different
insurance carriers we're just going to
have one national insurance carrier that
we're all going to pay into that
national insurance carrier is going to
negotiate
um the price of Health Care with doctors
the price of
um of drugs with the pharmaceutical
companies and so on to hopefully reduce
um uh prices and to implement a
different little bit of planning into
into the system because if there's only
one you know uh big National Insurance
Company
um that that company has a lot of weight
and power but you know you could still
visit your same doctor and
um there's still some uh it's not as
radical of a of a shift in that
direction and that's a dominant demand
of Bernie Sanders and the left right now
um there's 30 plus million people in the
US would be insured that currently
aren't insured if we move to this system
there's a lot of other people that are
underinsured or worried about how to pay
co-pays or or premiums involved I think
would be a net benefit for the vast
majority of the US
um population even if it was offset with
certain taxes because we spend a lot of
money out of pocket with with health
insurance and it's demand also that's
like widely popular so for me
it's almost like if you're trying to
build support for
um something like socialism we were
talking this Loft division of socialism
after capitalism or what worker
um ownership the means of production
would look like in practice and and so
on and by the way you're one of the few
interviewers who ever asked Mandy the
the details so it's good that I had a
I've been thinking of a rough sketch in
my head for the last you know
um whatever 16 years that I've been a
socialist
but
but we have to start in the here and now
and if you can't convince people that
the state should play a bigger role in
their health insurance and you can
convince Americans and a whole host of
other sectors that they should be living
in something closer to social democracy
how are you going to convince those
people that they should be worker
ownership of the means of production
it's kind of a ridiculous like leap
um if if you don't have the credibility
as the group of people organizing for
universal healthcare organizing for a 15
minimum wage and able to get the goods
and also in practice as we fight for
these reforms
ordinary people will have a better sense
at least my hope is of what it means to
be involved with politics and what
politics can do for their lives it's
positive because right now when we talk
about politics it often just seems that
we're talking about
um like a very glib cultural conflict
removed from the things that are
important in our lives whereas in truth
I think politics can be a tool for us to
make our lives better
yeah and there's like deep ideas here
where in some sense Universal Health
Care and worker collectives are not so
radically different that there is just
uh there's philosophical ideas to
explore and accept and also from my
perspective at least
maybe I'm wrong on this but it seems
like with a lot of things
at the core of Politics the right answer
from an alien perspective is not clear
like everybody's very certain of what's
the right answer everyone's certain
Universal Health Care is terrible or in
the case of Universal Health Care
majority of people think it's a good
idea but I don't think anyone knows
because I think that depends on cultural
history on the on the particular
dynamics of a country of a political
system on the Dynamics of the economic
system in this country of the changing
world the 21st century is different than
the 20th century maybe the failures of
Communism in the 20th century will not
be repeated in the 21st century or the
flip side of that may be capitalism will
actually truly flourish
are with the help of Automation in the
21st century I don't think anyone knows
so like you people like you are
basically saying like arguing for ideas
and we'll have to explore those ideas
together
um
why do you think if Universal Health
Care is popular
why don't we have Universal Health Care
in the United States well
democracy is a great thing political
democracy is wonderful it came from the
struggles of ordinary people to expand
suffrage and and so on but the economic
sphere entrenched power and the economic
sphere bleeds into our political
democracy so I think there's a lot of
people with the best interest in not
having Universal Health Care
um there's large Industries with the
best interest in not having Universal
Health Care
they pay for ads pay lobbyists they
influence government and they have made
it very difficult so you can't get
Universal Health Care
um done without the bill even if you
pass something you're trying to make a
change like Obamacare was supposed to
have a public option everybody's been
running on a public option in the
Democratic party for 12 13 years why
don't we have a public option
um people know that if people have the
choice of buying into a government plan
they might just keep that might be the
slow road to really having Universal
Health Care so I think a lot of it's
opposition
do you like that idea the public option
maybe you can like because is there
complexities like pre-existing
conditions
so isn't a public option
mean you can not have any insurance
until you get into trouble
and then you can if it covers
pre-existing conditions just start
paying for insurance then therefore
young people don't pay for insurance
isn't it better to go full in
I don't support a public option in part
because I think if we allow politicians
to just say hey I support a public
option well it's just kind of a way to
Signal your support for universal
healthcare would give us nothing and I
think that's what we saw under with
Biden a lot of other politicians that
have supported uh public option I think
in practice if a public option is
defined in such a way that it just means
you you
um you know by default can just opt in
to a public plan and let's say
hypothetically you don't even have to
pay for it then it's just a back door to
universal healthcare really quickly
because I think the vast majority of
people who aren't currently covered and
also a lot of employers to be honest
would probably drop their private
coverage if they knew their employees
can just get a public option and maybe
would only provide supplemental
insurance or or whatever else
um but I think the broad overarching
point of all these demands is to say
that
socialists need to be really connected
to the day-to-day struggles of people to
just improve their lives
so if you're feeling like you're paying
400 500 on the Obamacare market for
health insurance and that's hampering
your ability to do what you want to do
in your life then maybe you would
support a candidate who's for Universal
Health Care if you feel like you're
struggling to find work that you could
afford to pay your rent with or whatever
else maybe it'll support a candidate
committed to
um all sorts of mechanisms to reduce
housing prices or increase your power as
a as a tenant
um and you know whatever else so I think
it's like these day-to-day concerns need
to be connected to the more abstract and
lofty vision of change otherwise our
politics just becomes like this this
fantasy world thing that's that's you
know nice ideas to think about or debate
but but really won't make much of a
difference in people's lives